so in the last video we talked about the
year 1864 in the american civil war and
now we're getting down to the very end
of the war so in 1864
william tecumseh sherman had his sort of
famous march to the sea where he
captured atlanta and then carried on a
total war
through the state of georgia to savannah
and from savannah he turns north and
starts heading to the forces of grant so
he can back him up in a final victory
against lee
who has encamped enrichment meanwhile
abraham lincoln
wins the election of 1864 and is ready
to
bring this war to a close so let's move
on to 1865.
a lot happens very quickly in 1865
starting with in january congress passed
the 13th amendment the 13th amendment
outlawed slavery
for all time
so it's clear
that
when the south is brought back into the
united states it is going to be brought
back in without slavery there is no
option for slavery in the united states
going forward now grant after his
incredible victory
in tennessee in vicksburg has been going
after lee's army in virginia now lee has
holed up in richmond and eventually he
realizes his forces can't stay there
anymore they can't hold the city so in
the beginning of april they evacuate
richmond and on april 3rd the united
states forces occupy richmond and
abraham lincoln himself actually goes
down to visit richmond which he'd never
been to before
and he even goes to the government
building in richmond where confederate
president jefferson davis had governed
and goes into his office and he's there
less than 48 hours after davis himself
had left and then events after that
events take place very quickly so lee
falls back from richmond to petersburg
and grant is kind of marking him the
whole time and they
retreat across virginia to the west
lee's probably heading for lynchburg and
grant manages to cap catch up with him
at appomattox
and
at first lee thinks that he's actually
gonna fight at appomattox and then he
realizes he just does not have the men
necessary so
he invites grants to come and have a
parlay for surrender
and they meet this is actually a picture
of lee outside the house in appomattox
courthouse virginia where he surrendered
the army of northern virginia to grant
now that is not the actual end of the
civil war
but it's kind of the end for all intents
and purposes because lee is the general
in chief of the confederate armies
grant is likewise for the united states
and after this point it's just going to
be kind of a matter of time until all
the rest of the confederate armies
surrender so there's great celebration
in washington dc everyone is very happy
finally this four year long war where
620 000 americans have died
is over and abraham lincoln goes and
gives a speech talking about what
reconstruction is going to be like and
in this speech
he lays out that african americans after
the civil war are going to have
citizenship at least some of them and
the right to vote which is in keeping
with everything that he's really said
since the emancipation proclamation but
what he does not know is that this man
john wilkes booth is in the crowd that
day listening to him and when he hears
lincoln say that african americans are
going to have citizenship they're going
to have the right to vote he vows to
kill lincoln john wilkes booth is a
really interesting character we only
know so much about him he himself was a
famous actor in fact lincoln had seen
him perform a number of times and liked
him
even invited him to the white house
because he thought he was a great actor
but booth refused to go and see lincoln
and he was from a family of famous
actors i think kind of a modern-day
equivalent might be
the sheen family uh booth had a famous
brother who was also an actor and a
famous father who was also an actor just
like you know martin sheen's sons are
emilio estevez and charlie sheen today
so this would be like if emilio estevez
or charlie sheen suddenly decided to
murder the president which would be a
pretty incredibly big deal just as it
was then a booth was a confederate
sympathizer and almost certainly a
confederate spy who had gone up to
canada at some time to plot some
movement on behalf of the confederacy
and
he was an outright racist i think the
part where lincoln said that african
americans would have citizenship was
what pushed him over the edge
into assassinating lincoln originally he
had actually planned to kidnap lincoln
and ransom him for the end of the civil
war but after lee surrenders booth's
plan changes he wants to basically
decapitate the government so he
conspires with a couple of other people
and they plan that they're going to kill
all the highest people in government at
once so they're going to kill lincoln
they're going to kill general grant
they're going to kill william seward the
secretary of state and they're going to
kill andrew johnson the vice president
and booth thinks that perhaps in this
moment of panic that follows the
decapitation of the entire united states
government that perhaps something
positive for the south will happen
remember they had hoped that getting rid
of lincoln in the election of 1864 might
result in putting a government more
favorable to the south in office in the
north which didn't happen so perhaps
booth wants to do the same thing at this
time so booth reads in the newspaper
that abraham lincoln is going to be
attending a play at ford's theater that
evening
and booth is a regular at ford's theater
in fact he even has his mail delivered
there so it's kind of his home away from
home and
when booth goes to the theater with the
intent to kill lincoln he pretty much
just goes up to lincoln's box and
everyone knows who he is and they say hi
john and he just walks on by walks right
into lincoln's box uh shuts the door
behind him and shoots lincoln through
the back of the head at that point he
jumped on the stage from the the booth
which
is maybe 14 feet above the stage if
you've never been to ford's theater and
you have an opportunity i highly
recommend you go it's a really
interesting museum and historical place
and in the process he actually breaks
his ankle so in his running away he's
dealing with this broken ankle and
eventually he is captured and refuses to
be taken alive so he is killed and then
later the rest of the conspirators are
hanged for their participation in this
plot there's some confusion over what
booth said when he jumped out of the box
a lot of people say that he yelled sick
semper tyrannus
which means
thus always to tyrants
and is also the motto of the state of
virginia other people heard him say
things like i've done it or revenge for
the south
but sixth semper tyranis is kind of the
famous phrase that has come out of this
so booth is calling lincoln a tyrant and
that tyrants are eventually always
assassinated the rest of the
assassination plot from that evening
mostly failed
one of the conspirators lewis powell did
manage to get into william seward's
house and stab him he did not succeed in
killing him but he did wound seward very
badly uh the rest of the assassination
plots did not come to fruition
whatsoever and one thing you'll notice
is that only a few parts of the
confederate army have actually
surrendered at the time of lincoln's
assassination so the war is in some
cases still ongoing particularly in
north carolina
in raleigh and durham where
sherman's forces have come up through
south carolina and north carolina to
meet the forces of confederate general
joe johnston and it's on april the 26th
that joe johnston surrenders to william
tecumseh's sherman from that point
forward there are a few dribs and drabs
of other armies that are still
surrendering
interesting fact the last confederate
unit to surrender actually surrendered
in november of 1865 in liverpool england
this was a confederate ship that had
been sailing around and when they
finally came into port they officially
surrendered now after lincoln's
assassination which was an incredible
shock to the united states remember that
no president had ever been assassinated
before the power is then transferred to
andrew johnson
lincoln's vice president
and johnson's presidency is going to end
up being very problematic for a number
of reasons the most important of which
being that he's very sympathetic to the
south and with johnson in power as
president he's going to have a
considerable amount of conflict with the
american congress which is dominated by
radical republicans who think that
lincoln himself was not nearly punitive
enough toward the south there's going to
be just an incredible battle of wills
between congress and johnson that's
going to end with johnson being the
first american president to be impeached
and so thus endeth the civil war of the
united states with the north victorious
the southern states come back into the
union the rebellion in the south is
defeated slavery has ended and the era
of states rights is over in the next
video i'd like to talk just for a few
moments about the big takeaways about
the american civil war what is it that
makes it so important and what were the
lasting effects i'll get to that in the
next video